[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedriger hallo und guten Abend viel
Jubel bei den WM Gastgeberinnen der
Fußball-WM Christian das und mehr zeigt
uns später hab auch das Happy End der
Europameisterin guten Abend los geht es
jetzt mit einem wetterextrem in Europa
weiter Alarmstufe Rot vor allem in
Slowenien bleibt die Hochwasserlage
trotz sinkender Pegelstände katastrophal
der Motor stottert die deutsche
Wirtschaft kommt schlechter in Schwung
als andere Standorte in Europa
und Begeisterung in Down Under Gastgeber
Australien schickt die Dänen nach Hause
Engel an Fußball Frauen zittern sich in
die nächste Runde
[Musik]
gebrochene Dämme eingestürzte Häuser
überflutete Straßen und Gleise die
Naturkatastrophe in Slowenien ist so
groß dass sie Menschen ihr gesamtes Hab
und Gut nimmt und Sloweniens Regierung
in die Situation bringt Hilfe
anzufordern das Land Bad jetzt um
Unterstützung durch EU und NATO auch
Nachbarländer sind betroffen in
Österreich ist es der Süden des Landes
in Kroatien die Ufergebiete der Saale
nahe Zagreb und in Slowenien gelten zwei
Drittel des Landes als
Überschwemmungsgebiet in mehreren
Flussregionen herrscht Ausnahmezustand
für das kleine EU-Land zwischen Alpen
und Adria ist es ein Jahrhundert
Hochwasser Christoph
was ist alles kaputt von oben filmt die
Polizei ein Land in dem die Regenmassen
so vieles ins Rutschen brachten hänge
mit samthäusern Straßen sind verschüttet
Brücken zerstört ein normales Leben
erstmal nicht zu denken
auch nicht in Minger schnörklich von
ljubliana das alle dort überlebt haben
zählt vor allem für den Feuerwehrmann
Sam die Zeit als die Flut den
Kindergarten überschwemmte ist der
sofort hin
nicht stündlich ist das Wasser gestiegen
sondern minütlich wie in einem Film du
bist in der Titanic siehst die
Wassermassen kommen und musst einfach
nur funktionieren
alle Kinder brachten er und seine
Kollegen in Sicherheit wobei ihm genau
klar war im selben Moment zerstörte
dieselbe Flut gerade sein Haus seine
Möbel Dokumente und Familienfotos
inzwischen geht das Wasser zurück
Slowenien räumt auf braucht dafür Bagger
Hubschrauber Behelfsbrücken Hilfe kommt
haben andere Länder darunter auch
Deutschland versprochen eine grobe
Schätzung lässt an wie viel zu tun ist
in Milliardenhöhe dürften die Schäden
gehen
derweil fließt das Wasser quer durch
Slowenien nach Kroatien ab bringt dort
aktuell historische Pegelstände und
ungläubiges Staunen
Esten Träumen hätten wir uns vorstellen
können dass unser Fluss Drau so sehr
Überfließen könnte
größere Zerstörung in der weitgehend
flachen Landschaft wurde aber noch nicht
gemeldet
anders in Österreich wo viel von dem
Hochwasser herkommt nach und 350
Erdrutschen allein in der Steiermark und
in Kärnten sind die Betroffenen immer
noch fassungslos
und bei manchen Häusern ist weiter
unklar ob sie nicht doch noch
auseinanderbrechen
Slowenien also besonders stark betroffen
Wolf Christian Ulrich ist für uns dort
und zwar in Kamnik wir hören
wolf-christian die Pegelstände sinken
wieder wie ist die aktuelle Situation
die Situation hier den tieferen Lagen
des Landes ist jetzt stabil aber man
sieht eben auch die Schäden wie hinter
mir diese Brücke einfach kaputt gemacht
zerstört durch die Wassermassen die von
den Bergen hier runtergekommen sind
durch diesen Fluss deshalb ist die Hilfe
jetzt auch so wichtig die von der EU und
von der NATO angesagt ist eben auch
solche Behelfsbrücken von denen gerade
die Rede war hier helfen die aber eben
auch in den Bergen oben wo es immer noch
Ortschaften gibt die abgeschnitten sind
von der Außenwelt die Moment von der
Luft versorgt werden und wo man mit
solchen drücken dann überhaupt erstmal
hinbekommt die Struktur die
Infrastruktur hat hier im Land schweren
Schaden genommen es sind Brücken Straßen
Schienen wegen an manchen Stellen
allerdings auch die Trinkwasser und die
Stromversorgung und das ist deshalb so
tragisch dieser wirtschaftliche Schaden
weil jetzt Slowenien doch das Land war
hier in der Region nach der Wende dass
ich sehr sehr stark wirtschaftlich
entwickelt hatte und der wirtschaftliche
Schaden jetzt ist sehr groß für ein doch
so kleines Land nur 2,1 Millionen
Einwohner aber die stehen jetzt zusammen
und helfen sich heute wurde eine neue
App vorgestellt in der sich Slowenen
gegenseitig Hilfe anbieten können und
die war sofort in der ersten Stunde eine
Riesenerfolg man merkt daran auch dass
Gefühl hier vor Ort ist wir müssen uns
jetzt gemeinsam helfen wir müssen jetzt
zusammenstehen und wir werden auch
dieses Desaster gemeinsam meistern live
aus dem slowenischen Krisengebiet Wolf
Christian Ulrich vielen Dank
anders als in anderen EU-Ländern kommt
die deutsche Wirtschaft einfach nicht in
Schwung im Gegenteil die neuesten Zahlen
vom Statistischen Bundesamt sie sind
ernüchtern im Juni gegen die Produktion
deutscher Unternehmen im Vergleich zum
Vormonat um
1,5% zurück besonders betroffen die
Autoindustrie mit einem Minus von 3,5
und das Baugewerbe mit einem Minus von
2,8% hohe Zinsen Fachkräftemangel und
teure Energie einige der Gründe ja und
was kann man jetzt für die deutsche
Industrie tun Karl Hinterleitner dazu
sich Lehrende Auftragsbücher lähmende
Bürokratie Fachkräftemangel in der
Wirtschaft macht sich Unruhe breit
manche sehen den Standort Deutschland
gefährdet nach Ansicht der Opposition
ist das eine Folge der Politik der Ampel
als das einzige Industrieland auf der
Welt befindet sich Deutschland im Jahr
2023 in der Rezession und das hat etwas
mit der deutschen Wirtschaftspolitik zu
tun und deswegen sagen wir CDU und CSU
runter mit den Energiekosten und zwar
zum 1 Oktober das geht das hat der Bund
in der Hand das zu tun wir müssen uns
drum kümmern dass die Rahmenbedingungen
stimmen damit die Wirtschaft gut
arbeiten kann das fängt an mit
bezahlbaren Energiepreisen deswegen
sprechen viele jetzt von einem
transformationsstrompreis als Brücke hin
zur Klimaneutralität in die erneuerbaren
Energien die sind ja sehr günstig aber
noch nicht genügend gut ausgebaut ein
Streit also um den richtigen Weg beim
Kampf gegen die hohen Energiekosten
industriestrompreis
Steuererleichterungen Subventionen aber
die ganze Diskussion neu aufgeheizt
meinen Experten das Problem in
Deutschland gar nicht so neu und lösbar
die Unternehmen brauchen keine
Subvention sondern wir brauchen gute
Rahmenbedingungen innovativ werden zu
können diese Transformation und da muss
man sich ehrlich machen wird bedeuten
dass manche Unternehmen es nicht
schaffen werden aber dadurch auch neue
Unternehmen entstehen können doch auch
dafür brauche es mehr Klarheit bei den
Maßnahmen viele Probleme habe die
Politik über Jahre liegen lassen ich
glaube wir müssen ganz dringend davon
wegkommen und nur um die kurze Frist
Gedanken zu machen sozusagen nur an die
nächsten Bundestagswahlkampf zu denken
sondern wir müssen strukturell
langfristig vorbauen das Energie zur
Verfügung steht dass die
Standortbedingungen gut sind das
Bildungssystem gut ist und Fachkräfte
zur Verfügung stehen Aufgaben die die
Politik in Berlin und den Ländern lösen
muss möglichst bald
schauen wir jetzt in die Ukraine dort
hat die russische Armee erneut Städte
bombardiert in der Region rakev im Osten
des Landes sollen dabei zwei Menschen
getötet worden sein im Süden stand die
Stadt herson offenbar stundenlang unter
Beschuss hier wurde ein Wohnhaus
getroffen nach ukrainischen Angaben
kamen eine Bewohnerin ums Leben mehrere
Menschen wurden verletzt eine der
besseren Nachrichten vom Krieg Russland
und die Ukraine haben erneut Gefangene
ausgetauscht 22 Ukraine kamen frei wie
viele Russen das ist noch unklar
allerdings vermissen viele ukrainische
Familien noch Angehörige die verschleppt
wurden die Rede ist davon vielen tausend
Anne Brühl hat eine Frau getroffen die
erzählt was ihrer Familie passiert ist
butcherstraße 14d Olena Jus WAG will uns
diesen Ort zeigen das Haus in dem sie
ihr Mann und ihr Sohn die mal gefoltert
wurden von russischen Soldaten während
der Besetzung von Hostel
nach dem Verhör hat man uns Plastiktüten
über den Kopf gestirbt und danach haben
sie uns den Hals mit Klebeband umwickelt
sie haben versucht uns ersticken zu
lassen wir waren eine Zeit lang ohne
Sauerstoff und mein Sohn saß neben mir
und hat gesagt Mama ich kann nicht mehr
atmen
das sind die letzten Worte die Olena von
Dima hört die Männer werden nach
Russland verschleppt ihr Mann kommt
später frei der Sohn sitzt dort immer
noch im Gefängnis Olena yuswag zeigt uns
ein Foto von einer russischen Website es
ist mehr als vier Monate alt
es war gut zu sehen dass er damals am
Leben war ich hoffe das ist auch heute
noch so denn momentan gibt es keine
Information von ihm ihre Arbeit sagt Dr
Olena jusvak lenke sie ab sie ist
ärztliche Direktorin von vier
Polikliniken in der Gemeinde Horst
Tommel irpin Butcher liegen gleich
nebenan im ganzen Land wurden 25000
Zivilisten von den Russen verschleppt
die Zahl stammt vom ukrainischen
Menschenrechtsbeauftragten sie will
listen wie Dima zu Hause zeigt Olena uns
Fotos ihres Sohnes sie lässt nichts
unversucht um auf sein Schicksal und das
all der anderen aufmerksam zu machen
unsere Zivilisten frei zu lassen geben
Sie sie uns einfach zurück ohne jede
Forderung sie haben kein Recht sie
festzuhalten
sie hofft auf ein Wiedersehen in der
Küche steht für Dima immer ein Teller
auf dem Tisch
wir blicken nach Afrika nach dem Putsch
in Niger ist ein Ultimatum der
westafrikanischen Staatengruppe Eco was
abgelaufen diese hatten mit einem
militärischen Eingreifen gedroht sollte
der gestürzte Präsident bazoom nicht
wieder eingesetzt werden am Donnerstag
wollen die Staaten über ihr weiteres
Vorgehen beraten inzwischen haben die
Putschisten den Luftraum über Niger
erneut gesperrt ein Sprecher der selbst
ernannten Regierung warnte davor diesen
zu verletzen
aus Nairobi beobachtet Jan Fritzsche die
Lage Jan wonach sieht es jetzt aus und
was bedeutet die Situation für den Abzug
deutscher Soldaten aus Mali
da haben wir wohl ein technisches
Problem warten wir noch mal zwei
Sekunden vielleicht erholt sich das Bild
wieder
nein wir gehen wieder zurück und machen
mit dem nächsten Beitrag weiter es geht
um Großbritannien wer illegal dorthin
einreißt der wird festgenommen und soll
so schnell wie möglich abgeschoben
werden mit drastischen Gesetzen und
Maßnahmen versucht die britische
Regierung Migranten abzuschrecken
Jüngste ist Beispiel heute wurden erster
Asylsuchende auf ein Wohnschiff an der
Südküste verlegt
die ersten Flüchtlinge wurden am
Nachmittag aus einem nahegelegenen Hotel
zum wohnchef im Hafen von Portland
gebracht begleitet von Anwohnerprotesten
gegen die Flüchtlingspolitik der
konservativen Regierung
wir hoffen dass diese Menschen nicht
weiter als Sündenböcke
instrumentalisiert und verfolgt werden
bis zu 500 Asylbewerber sollen auf dem
Schiff Platz finden die Behörden wollen
so Kosten für eine Hotelunterbringung
sparen und neue Flüchtlinge abschrecken
im letzten Jahr kamen rund 45.000
Menschen meist in kleinen boten über den
Ärmelkanal das will die Regierung
unterbinden auch weil sie darin ein
wichtiges Wahlkampfthema sieht
die gute Gesetz hat oberste Priorität
wer illegal einreist muss festgenommen
und in sein Heimatland abgeschoben
werden wenn das sicher ist
so Verschaffung des Asylrechts wollte
die Regierung auch Flüchtlinge nach
Ruanda abschieben ein Gericht stoppte
die Umsetzung vorerst kritiker werfen
der Regierung in London vor
flüchtlingsrechte bewusst zu missachten
obwohl die Zahlen im Vergleich zu
Deutschland beispielsweise relativ
gering sein
Asylanträgen wächst immer weiter weil
die Regierung die Fälle nicht bearbeiten
will sondern stattdessen Flüchtlinge nur
auslagern will
das Wohnschiff zu betonen die Behörden
sei kein Gefängnis die Bewohner könnten
tagsüber auch an Land gehen
zurück nach Deutschland eigentlich will
die Post ja gerne vorzeitig nämlich
schon nächstes Jahr das Briefporto
erhöhen sie darf aber nicht das Porto
würde ausreichen um die Kosten zu decken
das sagt die Bundesnetzagentur 85 Cent
kostet z.B der Standardbrief zur Zeit
scharfe Kritik kommt von der Post damit
würde die flächendeckende Versorgung in
Deutschland gefährdet
früher oder später geht die Rente ja
jeden etwas an je früher man sich
kümmert desto besser allerdings herrscht
da viel Unsicherheit wie und ob neben
dem Beruf zusätzlich vorgesorgt werden
muss und auch wie viel man am Job Ende
wirklich ausgezahlt bekommt wie so oft
sollen uns auch hier digitale Angebote
weiterhelfen Orientierung bieten sie
schon aber einiges fehlt noch für uns
Markus wollte er jetzt zeigt
es sind Aussicht von Experten
alarmierende Zahlen fast ein Viertel der
Menschen in Deutschland befasst sich nie
mit altersvorsorgeplanung das zeigt eine
aktuelle Studie viele und vor allem
jüngere fühlen sich schlecht informiert
ja also was ich mal an Rente bekommen
werde nee weiß jetzt eigentlich nicht
nee
ich bin selbstständig deswegen ist bei
mir noch mal ein bisschen schwieriger
ich muss wahrscheinlich dann in die
private Rentenkasse einzahlen und habe
bis jetzt gar keine Vorstellungen davon
helfen soll eine neue Plattform
rentenübersicht.de sie fasst zusammen
was der Nutzer später zu erwarten hat an
gesetzlicher betrieblicher und privater
Altersvorsorge nach den ersten Wochen
Pilotphase ist die Rentenversicherung
zufrieden
290.000 Anfragen wurden bisher gestellt
Verbraucherschützer finden die Plattform
gut sehen aber einige Schwachstellen man
kann nicht sehen was man für
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge im Alter
zahlen muss wie Krankenversicherung man
kann auch nicht sehen wie hoch die
Steuer sein wird man kann also auch gar
nicht
selbstbestimmt seine Rentenlücke
errechnen
Professor Andreas entwickelt gerade eine
App die genau das kann und die Frage
beantwortet reicht die Rente wie können
wir Menschen helfen bessere
Finanzentscheidungen zu treffen und das
geht neuerdings oder heutzutage mal nur
über eine App letztlich geht es darum
finanzielle Unabhängigkeit zu erreichen
ohne jetzt Produkte zu verkaufen Ende
des Jahres startet die neue
rentenübersicht in den Regelbetrieb die
jährliche schriftliche Informationen
soll es jedoch weiterhin geben
wieder große Emotionen bei der
Fußball-WM und wieder seine Art Krimi
Christin
sicherten sich die Europameisterinnen
aus England in Brisbane den
Viertelfinale Einzug und damit den
Turnier Verbleib nach der Verlängerung
hatte es 0:0 gestanden ein wahrlich
mühsamer Auftritt gegen Nigeria
Mitleid für die gegnerische Torfrau fast
wichtiger als der eigene Jubel eine
tolle Geste der englischen Spielerinnen
zu vorne Nigeria lange Zeit das bessere
Team mit den besseren Chancen Plan tree
die Latte rettet England und gleiches
passiert in der zweiten Hälfte nach
Kopfball von Kanu
0:0 kurz vor Ende der regulären
Spielzeit diese täglichkeit von Lauren
James die Folge Platzverweis aber
England schafft es trotzdem in die
Verlängerung und dann ins
Elfmeterschießen dort vergeben operanosi
und hier hallo sie für Nigeria England
nur mit einem Fehlschuss und Klo Kelly
kann die Begegnung entscheiden und sie
verwandelt sicher 4 zu 2m
Elfmeterschießen über uns sei Dank
wir haben sie tatsächlich trainiert und
es hat funktioniert
so schafft es England mit Glück ins
Viertelfinale
ja und auch die Australierinnen sind in
dieser packenden WM Endrunde weiter
dabei und versetzen das Gastgeberland in
einen Fußballrausch beflügelt vom
Heimvorteil gingen die Mathildas in
Sydney gegen die Dänen in der 29 minute
durch Kettling Ford in Führung in der 70
Minute erhörte helik Reso zum 2:0
entstand Partystimmung in Australien was
völlig verdient im Viertelfinale steht
und dort geht es entweder gegen
Frankreich oder Marokko weiter der
letzte achtelfinalspieltag morgen im ZDF
von 9:45 Uhr an und alle Tore alle
Höhepunkte der WM gibt es bei uns auch
gebündelt online unter ZDF heute.de
dritte Medaille für Lea Sophie Friedrich
bei den radweltmeisterschaften im
schottischen Glasgow im kairin reichte
es für die 23-Jährige Sprinterin diesmal
zu Bronze was sie zunächst etwas
enttäuschte denn ihr Ziel war nach zwei
WM Titel nacheinander der Hattrick in
dieser Disziplin ich muss mir vor Augen
halten dass man nicht immer gewinnen
kann so ihr Fazit
kann man nur sagen wie wahr
Dankeschön Christin und bevor wir an die
Kollegin vom Wetter abgeben schon mal
der Hinweis an einigen Orten im Norden
da müssen Urlauber wohl umplanen denn
ein Sturmtief führt an der Ostseeküste
vereinzelt zu orkanartigen Bönen dazu
kommt dann teils heftiger Regen auf See
könnte es ungemütlich werden die
Fährverbindungen zu den Inseln hinsee
und Rügen die wurden eingestellt
ja mehr zu den stürmischen Aussichten
wie gesagt gleich von Katja horneffer
zum heute journal begrüßt sie später um
21:45 Uhr Maria das lomka das war die 19
Uhr Ausgabe am Montag schönen Abend und
gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend obwohl das Regen dringende
Sturmtief Zacharias inzwischen
Skandinavien erreicht hat bekommen wir
doch heute Nacht noch schwere Sturmböen
ab hier in der Küste mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von 100 Kilometern
pro Stunde bei uns lässt der Regen erst
mal nach und die Temperaturen sinken an
der Küste auf 15 bis 13 Grad sonst wird
es deutlich kälter mit 12 bis 6 Grad und
dann kältesten ist es am Alten Markt
dort wie auch vor allen Dingen in
Richtung Südwesten ist der Himmel auch
klar der Regen lässt erstmal nach aber
morgen kommt schon gleich der nächste
hinterher der ist zum Teil mit Gewittern
durchsetzt der kräftige Wind lässt auch
allmählich etwas nach Freund hier sieht
sie aus im südlichen Brandenburg und in
Sachsen-Anhalt die Regenfälle haben bis
zum Mittag ungefähr die Mittelgebirge
erreicht in Süddeutschland wechseln
morgen Sonnenschein und wolkenfreundlich
miteinander ab und zum Teil ist es auch
Strahlen sonnig wir haben Alpenrand oder
auch am Oberrhein am Oberrhein steigen
morgen die Temperaturen bis 24 Grad in
den östlichen Mittelgebirgen und auch in
Schleswig-Holstein bleibt es bei 17 Grad
deutlich kühler auch am Mittwoch gibt's
noch Regenfälle im Norden und im Osten
Deutschlands danach wird es von
Südwesten deutlich sonniger und Wärme
mit bis zu 29 Grad am Freitag guten
Abend